[Musique]
une performance de haut vol le jeu de
mot est facile pour un exploit qui ne
l'est pas la pluie et le vent n'ont pas
fait trembler tatiana mossot bonganga la
funambule à surplomber la perspective de
marta pan accompagnés d'artistes en live
[Musique]
ce qu'on défend avec la compagnie c'est
qu'il n'ya pas juste une funambule il ya
des musiciens et il ya aussi tout un tas
de personnes qui viennent nous aider je
passe vous avez vu les cavaliers teese
qui sont tenus par part par des
personnes c'est des habitants de saint
quentin en yvelines
donc ouais c'est aussi la rencontre et
le fait de vivre quelque chose tous
ensemble un quart d'heure de traversée
d'une longueur de 100 m à 20 mètres de
hauteur
l'artiste a enchaîné les figures malgré
le temps le public était venu en nombre
la grâce de sept funambules la beauté
des figures la musique toutes
magnifiques un beau grand spectacle au
coeur de saint quentin c'est chouette
c'est super g première fois je vois ça
c'est vraiment très audacieux incroyable
mais je voudrais vraiment pas le faire
j'ai trouvé que c'était chouette qu'elle
était très forte pour parfaire sa
c'était impressionnant
c'était même stressant pour nous
peut-être plus que pour elle c'est
incroyable
[Musique]
une performance vécu entre inquiétude
l'artiste évolue son sécurité et poésie
par le public un moment sur le fil
[Musique]
oh